they don't hear it off should be back
now can you guys hear us
can you hear us literally just watching
your mouth move I can lip-read can you
guys hear us like gravity ray wrong yes
or no somebody what's up fool there it
is thank you to Frank DeJesus was so
full part cast
what's a full podcast for those of you
guys who are watching this and listening
to this on Friday it's gonna be a
repeater but I guess then welcome to the
worst of food podcast we got Roderigo
Roderigo here with your Torres the
co-host of the year two years running
maybe three we never know
Lisa Esparza right here finally got a
mic by unpopular demand and Emma Emma
over there on the Wheels of Steel the
engineer the brains behind all this
what's up fool yeah my steering all the
way up when I started working good for
you but we blew that era looked at your
lucky roadie literally laughs this show
is brought to you by the people who said
you ain't gonna be [ __ ] you ain't nobody
and [ __ ] you man you know any we're
never funny
you [ __ ] your fat ass you drugged-out it
you piece of [ __ ] how many people say
you ain't gonna be sheriff really you
know get the trailer park nobody's ever
said that okay I told you like we're
gonna get braces
let that okay Essos in the fourth grade
they told me I had to sharp it this guy
said you have the sharpest nose I've
ever seen you come back I come back
nobody said anything is that back in the
day we had that little coat little fur
coat oh that my teacher made fun of me
for having a dirty coat Tweety Bird my
teacher it was a substitute teacher that
we had for like two weeks and he made
fun of me because I was poor we couldn't
afford the washing machine all the time
and
so my my coat was dirty and he made
because I was pretending it was like a
fur coat well now I don't know why I
pictured by just picking the little bird
man from from my horror story
whatever that movie is called poor
stories on AMC FX American horns
American horror stories yeah Birdman a
little bird guy for no fun our fun house
he got that fool got rolled over
Hollywood had died bro beep beep what's
awful nobody really instead are they
gonna be [ __ ] man
I think that to my face or nothing like
that I thought people right people
doubted me especially the people who are
like very successful people opening up
old wounds can't let it go sure put that
behind them let's get back to fourth
grade so that Pete cone what do you say
what do you call you he just say no I
said oh he was just like story time this
is fourth grade and everything bad
happen in 4th grade my dad left on 4th
grade all that stuff I was having a
rough time we were broke as [ __ ] I was
eating out of trash cans but anyway I
put on this coat and I said he's at his
story time and I said well let me get my
fur coat first I was getting all cozy
right to listen to the story me what'd
he say and he said you better wash your
fur coat or something like that and the
whole class giving you money for some
Brad clean this is a [ __ ] teacher I'm
crying now tearing up to do a pretty
coat again I don't think I tried I think
I tried to wash it with bar soap no like
kids you know they play and they get the
arms dirty right but see my mom had
limited amount of quarters so we didn't
always have
you know super clean clothes and we had
to hand me down they're all torn well I
had that first I had to get my brother's
girl clothes you know they we have any
money so yeah we also we all had free
shoes from somewhere we went and picked
out these all these no name brand no
Nike no and it was around that time this
was the 80s
Nike polo eyes are coming out yeah like
you could you know it was named brand
central coming out that was all new
adidas nike like all that if you were
pro kids you were loser bro Pro Inc this
was 81 roll kids 80 81
wow man yeah the fur coat huh it wasn't
for it was one of those you know like
waterproof jacket I was just pretending
I was a kid I was just being like
overdramatic like I'm getting cozy for
this story time hilarious like he labels
it with it with that partying with a red
dot he was wearing the cardigan
how do they see other joking where he
gave her the the coat oh the housekeeper
they're made for the she said and then I
said what is that fabric and he said
it's cashmere and I said I love it can I
please have no get away from me without
the teacher a real teacher it was a
substitute but we had him for like two
or three weeks why teach a blanket he
was a white teacher
yeah you better watch that cold this was
a suburban school that we didn't we
didn't get bused to but we had it my mom
took us but we walked a lot over there
but we were allowed to go there for some
reason and it wasn't near that we lived
in the section 8 housing like way on the
outskirts over there an apartment
building tough protocol may Mar gonna
die with a fur coat it's like dirty fur
coat like you know how kids get dirty
sleeves like from like plan and stuff
but there weren't that many washings
going on man the German stepmother Mira
bro thinking you're cooler when your
brothers fat buy bagged on you haha dude
a group of times whatever you think you
would rather have a lot of rivalry
although we're always cool
it's always cool but we always bag on
each other like hardcore like I did this
I did this tape one time I did the
lyrics to give it away on Hot Chili
Peppers for the first time the mouse
came to my house I recorded your brand
new lyrics oh yeah give it away there
dude so the first time the mouse came to
my house a fool played it like full
blast in the garage took the tape out
ran away came back play that [ __ ] again
I was like oh my god where's that tape I
don't know that team has to be somewhere
dog that's a that was like a hardcore
embarrassment hell yeah bro what's up my
brother
brother angel he was going out to the
club and now for wearing a trench a
black trench coat he's a moderate martyr
and he had hair slicked back and that
Foose foot was worried of white v-neck
oh my god black pants and boots right
Duran Duran well I will burn up the ride
No Mas Roberto Duran Duran bro he was
standing there bro and I heard our food
says I'm Sicilian oh my god okay I don't
know yeah no you can't spell that shitty
you said I look like the Sicilian Prince
bro whoa
that's what I'm talking about confidence
right there does that was darkness bars
I was cool friend okay he was having a
phone booth talking to this chick line
really who's gonna go to with Hollywood
and go to this and then I'm I gotta go
cuz we leave right now we guys gonna go
get my brother on the other line
I was laid over he's gonna DJ like he's
gonna teach wanna but you don't want to
say everyone else Tijuana so he [ __ ]
hung up and you could hear my brother
[ __ ] that four by the other line
and that's back in the day when you have
the two phones you can pick one up hear
somebody talking in like you know but in
the conversation
well mama listen talk nah dude they
wouldn't like that dude my mom's just
something with you know if we messed up
didn't you go and they're like you know
break [ __ ] or take it away though you
hold your mom what you only listen the
other line my mom was the nosiest mom
you could ever imagine she read my diary
I wrote notes to her in my diary like
[ __ ] I know you know I said to her face
but I would write it in the my diary cuz
I knew she read it and I knew that if
she said anything to me I would know she
read it you know if she said anything
about the languages using I wrote in
somebody's your diary ones oh my like
somebody I found somebody's diary and I
waited and I will escape a month then I
roll out some chicks house huh oh the
chick called grow and I thought was
gonna get laid a bad story okay I
thought gonna get laid man but all she
did was like give me a bomb with some
weed and let me in a room and locked it
bro goddamn dog house I broke that one's
loose but I get lucky right and although
hi I would leave bro that's what your
morning
are you sick dog scratching a Hodor but
though the bathroom I might my room but
she was to her room and so I started
digging out was our high bro I was
trying to smoke everything I was super
high and start looking around everything
bro and I found a bunch of like
yearbooks and diary don't you were
little you know the stuff that she
collected and all that [ __ ] then I
finally got to the her diary the recent
one and I saw that um that she were
broken up about somebody right she was
all happy at one time then then Tim
laughs she was sad and heartbroken hard
time you know I've been having a hard
time they need
whoa I don't know where to find myself I
find myself alone this big-ass house
lucky fools in the room you know I
bought a dog he's grown now whatever and
then I wonder back to two months later
too much for two months forward I'm
October 6 still wondering what's going
on with Felipe [ __ ] dry as hell right
now still maybe she'll give us a [ __ ]
right now and my person wouldn't be so
dry oh man a room alone what a stupid
ass [ __ ] I'm sorry longer little just
dis unibrow [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah man
it was going great [ __ ] what did she
think you just needed a place to stay or
yeah I don't know what happened man
that's like you're not gonna get none
tonight like I was outside bro the
rocket was out what's up boo you should
do a stash with two Meg's come on bro
vegan dinner idea I gotta cook food just
make some fideo bro just don't use no
[ __ ] my tech I use butter you'll be
all right
my real crews G's in that house what's
up man how was Toby Hicks this weekend
bro what have you lost
turning chicken how about that food
oppression to me oh my god so we hate
when impersonate rosevilla Tories last
week
yo lady gonna leave you for fartin nah
man oh man you even watch a movie and it
usually happens on the Coen brothers
movies the Coen Brothers movie they did
Fargo they did no country for old man
raised in Arizona
oh brother were out thou
- crosstie which a killer still can't
get through that movie fall asleep every
I fall asleep every time they bury what
they tell they leave up John Turturro
in the woods oh that actor in the game
oh my god I forgot
Gabriel Isha's sister loves that fool if
loves and loves that movie and she goes
oh my god everything he's doing he's
amazing and she had like pictures of a
grown woman with two kids bro stop being
a realist yes if you were a Hollywood
run into him you call me not so on for
real Bulgaria burns the only white boy I
would ever leave my family for whoa I'm
escorting her but that would that's what
her love for Gabriel Burgos so that's
her like man crush Monday right there
hell yeah bro Babs crush every day hey
so what's up will you say it about uh
till we were talking about Toby Hicks
you were bars huh oh man we went to war
we did a show at Lenox City it was
amazing it was a good crowd right it was
sold out no it wasn't sold out but it's
a good crowd there's some good we ate at
the employees lounge tell her what
happened brothers taking allows both oh
man okay first of all man they give out
Jersey they give us the Belcher's to eat
sometimes you know they usually $50 or a
hundred fifty bucks because we gotta eat
um we have to eat right in the hotel but
this time they only give us 16 bucks
yeah you got 16 then we got eight no
yeah that's what Toby's out what am I
gonna get for $8.00 Sabri yeah 25 it was
good I like my cafeteria food we'd be
eating in hospitals I'm surprised
there's any food the way that gig was
going
big drill so unhelpful that's a big
drought
yeah big Dre at MGM over there Maryland
DMV right DC Maryland Virginia little
access sir but what's his name uh he
ain't like a king Toby are and then he
started breaking the world down yeah man
he was too many wines Friday September
14 of being Las Vegas at the Hard Rock
Casino and yes if you got an email that
it's nine o'clock that is right it's
nine o'clock Ticketmaster messed up and
the show is that 9:00 p.m. so hell yeah
we'll be there if not at 8:00 Saturday
September 15 are being Laughlin Nevada
Edgewater Casino with Rodrigo Torres
Johnny Rocco who the [ __ ] is Johnny and
Jay Lamont what's up April my hand crane
September 22 or 22nd we're coming to
Lexington Kentucky at the comedy off
Broadway anybody there driving six hours
to this show
don't worry about the ticket I got you
the email it's like if you're between
one hour or two hours of the show I got
you don't worry about it Lexie next to
Kentucky anybody out there doing
business over there traveling in the
area on the way to somewhere cool stop
by I got you November September 29
Abiathar springfield massachusetts at
the city stage Symphony Hall everybody
in Boston I will see you there
we're working with the one and only Dan
Smith and with Rio Torres and me West
Nyack New York I'm coming to West Nyack
in October get ready
I'm coming also to Dallas Houston Texas
Tampa Florida Seattle and Reno a lot of
dates in October for months again you
gonna be a temper
I'm planning so all of them but I
haven't told him about it
shot a man in Reno Corona it's been a
while so it's been the Ybor City man how
you liking Corona I like it you know
like the only thing that I can't be
overdoing is I can't have too many
expressos and too many cigars because at
one time I had like four expressos and
two cigars
I turned green man I mean hey like get
into the like you're the palate yeah cuz
I've done like you know two or whatever
and that gets me like like I want to
puke yeah yeah cool but it's like kind
of like like stony weed but just a
different feeling
smoking backwards what's up fool ah man
Johnny Roku trying to bring in the
peanut butter and jelly in a jar and a
big piece of bread it's all about - the
peanut butter and jelly but that were
walking with a bread are tired and Toby
was cooking a mimosa no more he could
bring why don't he just check it so the
last time a little man with a Chinese
soup yeah but this is paste yeah Charlie
were so fool you got Felipe where are we
going to check Felipe world.com people
holiday today
oh the Sacramento area maybe I think
it's gonna be like good MA yeah I
figured a mile again at that casino what
was it
Colusa no other one underbelly Lincoln
California yeah yeah you're calling that
angel What's Up boo skill hirsute trying
to hang out come on
[Laughter]
J Baroness he just said Tampa in October
that says was so fooled by the we're
trying to call ain't Joe is farther
south at my brother he's living in
Tijuana Mexico
let's TV picks up what's up man
louder yeah speak up louder ok hold on
bro what's up can you hear me can you
hear me now
perfect ok here you were sup this is my
brother angel Esparza Hey laughs we're
living in Tijuana Mexico what's up man
we're doing the podcast right now how's
it going long time no see long time no
talk man well the last time I saw you I
met you those we saw you at we say a
creepy one time at a party Thanksgiving
marshes have arrived Fernando's at the
time right he was with your mom are you
there yeah so you're known as a party
yeah
you saw me what party I was at a party
I think Thanksgiving party yes thanks
good that's when you made that pumpkin
cake with Tuesday oh yeah I look good K
good ass cake so what's the leg man what
you doing over there right now
you're so sober what you doing I just
want you carry me at night don't be like
a church the trust you have to be
security chill out of the end but you
still here - over here
I remember remember used to work that
security job and he told me used to go
in there with your back when your
sleeping bag
you'd say be honest II said time you say
again my friends your girlfriend your
girlfriend so what's up fool man what's
up man was 29 with everybody the
projects I never go over there different
name make it seem like it's not bad
anymore but it's still bad right that's
bad
because the Chaparro still live there a
beaver I know man the depth that bag has
plea cos they [ __ ] family has leaked
a Z the first generation do get along
with the second generation yeah somebody
asking somebody asking me you know right
now on YouTube we're showing the video
live and people are asking questions on
YouTube they ask you who's on the phone
baby Joker the rescue them this video
are usually used in my social security
number
they turn the thermostat down there
Cammi prophet was so fool somebody's
Dana you stayed a meteor who Leah's
house some guy named Omar Gonzalez what
the [ __ ] I said what's up was a Hong
Kong club in Tijuana and Adelitas
shaving-cream a you will go there what's
up man were little kids and you were
going to that school
Sierra Park Elementary School in El
Sereno right yeah huh they travel to a
school and I got I got left in a ghetto
at school bro let me know how to make
[ __ ] your boy in arrows a Mickey knives
not a pencil
he's over there bro being a foreign
exchange true that I'm over here bro
place [ __ ] you [ __ ] you're breaking
spoons world in the last time fighting
with pencils how that whole foreign
exchange didn't went down how did that
how did he sign up how did you how did
you sign up for that foreign exchange to
learn honey my mom find out did he take
a kid from the party that we do
something with him the truth the school
chose you yeah he live in the housing
projects and the other kids they live a
normal house this did they test you for
damn no they said I was gay
get the hell that I know I know I know I
know manipulate people I think all three
so what happened when how did how did
that family choose you or they chose
their family for you with Javier Prieto
did hear me they got you it was it wow
man that you have to pay KITT my mother
too freaked out when she saw that bill
but just to pay for the plane ticket
[Laughter]
monasteries badness so what the phone
going to eat now when you go to Mexico
some more pillows there a big-ass house
where Mexico did you go people have more
money right there makes it look Mexico
City right yeah that's right Polanco
right yeah it's right next to it near
yeah you can walk across the street to
the Museum of Anthropology right there
nope oil turnip or Alana Jews you care
about them assure the nurse their second
three so whoa they're like when you got
there or next how did they greet you
we have no sign caviar from the airport
I did you have to get a cab get a cab
no Inca kid you got a school bus that we
all made of somewhere you did not so
they met you with a big sign how do we
mean happier when he got to the art -
Ally eggs I don't remember man who
picked them up that was [ __ ] I always
think about it he walked up man because
he's a upper middle class kid this guy's
playing pop pool tackle football that
early 80 but which is unheard of you
gotta have money to play that [ __ ] back
his sisters in fencing class and when
she died making offenses like we found
you alone she's got me playing sword
fights and he shows up man and man oh oh
they tell you on the side you know like
you got a belt like he got a fucked-up
deal he said it's a simple
[Laughter]
I found don't say anything that's
crazy-making we will take the full round
with us and everybody get Oh bro like
it'll probably his first time around
African Americans and Vietnamese at the
same time that he would not buy it from
anybody and then hey Jose some stuff
back home that kind of racist comes in
at amigo El mono even Vinci benching
gone and then when I watch more no more
eager for more normal yeah what is that
it's worth it saying the n-word in
Mexico huh
right chimpanzee that was another
neighbor may mean pinguin maybe beween
yeah Jim Oh neato but as you go tell my
mom and I said there's no time and don't
ever say that again we all get knocked
out by the silver tooth guy maybe James
don't play war died oh hi I'm a high
diving in triple Lindy done Prieto egg
to the bar is dear bro doing a badness
all a commercial went to a private
school he showed up in the progress and
everybody's doing whatever they want
you surprised the way to stand in life a
free lunch
whoa rule like there was no like panic
like everybody reads the rules like Lord
of the Flies how about that one time he
bought one ice cream anymore that would
totally be my move he bought one bro I
had to give five legs to that brother we
pulled over it huh you may know it took
a teenager took it shoplifting you
created a monster II but he don't know
how to shoplift bro it was obvious the
way he did it when we get to a fight
with another student and there was
another kid from Mexico and he was there
with another white boy and now if we was
having a hard time with that white boy
huh yeah they were pretty cute
they weren't like Carlton from Fresh
Prince
[Laughter]
how about man that was how about where
now when I'm there man so you went you
want to go see the pyramids with his
family huh and that really in front of
it bro we put it in for Griffith Park
who did this experiment who conducted
this experiment a training place this
was this brand off of Mortimer Duke yeah
yeah I mean you get a nice experience
over there but so you eat a really
really good food over there with
restaurants the ways that you eat pop
basses older like correct Spanish no
slang Wow though there hasn't been
killing a dog hey man so that so his
family spoke correct Spanish like though
there is piglet umami way let that word
never came out of their mom huh they
were in Spain
Wow man yeah hit a sister right two
little sisters yeah what do you think
that food doing right now it's just a
recovering from the earthquake in Mexico
oh all right could that happen after he
got home bro remember right now when
anything remember where we took that
foot to the beach and he was surprised
that my dad had a he was taking her in a
freeway on the truck and everybody just
have to hold on crazy that must be crazy
man cuz he went from having their own
bed Jerry your own room when you were
with her no it's crazy because the room
was huge on then when he got to our
house he had to share a bunk bed row
with me and Mina me and Albert so he had
this thing with another person or you
and Albert shared a bed and yeah I know
what time he but he better he been a
little uh one of the little football
games and you want to share so I took
that [ __ ] and you got all mad at the end
because um my dad - my dad had a magic
mountain tickets but I only got one for
himself and that kid at me
agent sympathy nothing's just children
how'd you feel man
did you feel like that [ __ ] and that
first night if I was that exchange
student now it'd have been like planning
my way to tell you man the first night
he showed up doing those shootings
outside and he didn't know what to do he
felt like it was like a lot of shooting
outside and we live right to a freeway
and then like next door Hills but he'll
bite I scoffs next door from Hong and
duck and young he was surprised by that
that was the most shocking part that he
didn't know how dark he was he swears he
wasn't black I want to build a fucked-up
there should be a movie bro
isn't that crazy let's say that kid was
a bit much of felt that he got the bad
end of the deal right Trading Places
yeah
what's up fools what's it like out there
Manuel you a nom well you live in Mexico
Tijuana first or you went to to keep an
eye on it well my dad is they've been
there yet I've been there
however done is it this to a big river
there yeah but they finally put a dam
put a dam yeah any part then it rings
before a ring for about 20 minutes and I
know I always tell people that they're
my dad's hometown just to go inside the
house you gotta take an extra step
because building a building on a big
block because the river hotel I don't
know who built it but it's built because
there's no sewers so the river is built
to to get flooded and then the water
somehow because the way the town is
built the water flushes out the valley
then they're in a valley yeah but I
don't where there's no damn they've
never been a dam they've never been a
way to stop the river coming in so it
does pictures of my father my uncle
Teodoro and my father and my mom holding
me as a child and the water is up above
other kneecaps
oh yeah but the water is just flowing
and it's actually if you're if you're a
little kiddo take you away but it just
it flows out the town and meets the
river at the other side but it just
that's the way it was built they have a
dam now they fixed it now three feet
tall yes what yeah you know why cuz in
the water remember my grandma used to
live across the street from that up by
there yeah we should get free bread
because they they were scared of my
grandma
she would like the Mafia there huh
Turkish Oi so you have work right now
just just talking or working I saw your
daughter your granddaughters better
boxing now I can't imagine she's like
nine right she's like seven eight she
likes David and she's boxed in love -
she's boxing up 13 Rhodes
she looks tough she is tough
yeah we're gonna see Michelle this
weekend we're gonna see your daughter
this weekend at that Vegas for the
triple G Canelo fight yeah I think so
I'm the guy I'm the guy from Louie told
me to Steve to put all your money on the
draw what's that
I mean where that's how you make more
money look at look at their money [ __ ]
out right with more times
yeah they gotta run this one was so full
with realtor is Lisa Esparza we got a
Joe as far as uh the madam is missing in
action in Tijuana Mexico and Colonia
Tracy what's the thing you miss the most
about being what you miss the most about
LA
when I miss about Ellie drinking water
just being able to trust it off yeah
look at the water there's bad you know
ever since they said that they're
feeding dog the changeful places that
was the last American no China for the
money the dogs so whatsoever
so what's always true for the plenty you
know Rick Dees in the morning yeah he's
to have a fool of a corner and there is
one up one day and this traffic is not
right now right and it wasn't but that
comes the America but that came in Mary
was talking to his friends about this
trip he took and then angel y'all know
what so a true love Widow right is that
off
[Laughter]
I forgot about that fool he's a Telugu
with SQL bro it was a lot - all right
he always taught me was to hew like in a
toilet like hey Joey any weapon any
women out there
ah sorry this will say what happened Oh
Tito chop word on the level 505 what's
up man will you eat up there man that's
good you talk close you don't hear
anything anymore I found I found a
Subway sandwich thing it's kind of far
from my house bar that's where I go get
food they have a woman from we went to a
good place over there
Telefonica the 40 car yeah it's a guest
room best rope like outdoor restaurants
like taco trucks but all in one little
spot
what's up I made a lot of a lot of a lot
of cholos from our liova that they got
deported yeah they're over there trying
to change their lives it must be hard to
be to get deported and you were a
gangster and you trying to live over
there turn a gang bang to brainstorm
he's gonna run all that ones yeah well
what are they catch me
it's TJ crazy up there right now dude
TJ TJ is crazy because they're
recruiting actually recruiting in
California they're cartels yeah yeah do
they want a load G careless yeah don't
want to find people with the real guns
the singing star tonight we're doing
work what's it like over there man well
you weren't we we will you work out it
makes it was [ __ ] dusty hell and they
play bird trash huh yeah they're crazy
and then and then they wonder why some
kids are born with with some kind of
mental different difficulties did you
were burning plastic when she was pretty
somebody said TJ's crazy cuz a Jewess
parts that lives there I wasn't of
trouble to tell you what's up Jackie
Escalera
hit me up on Facebook yeah we had his
father depart Ken Reyes Calera
he was of your slurring and [ __ ] Bernie
game was so full man you know we have a
friend named Adam Murray man and that
full box top bro can't buy a [ __ ]
suit game play but stop he's diversify
tell you can't buy a car buddy bar stock
is the worst decision yeah
oh so you're out there man have you run
into my our cousin Xavier or Baldo I
want to borrow found a way to stop being
equal narrows oh yeah I saw their system
she does a Reno a big house that happens
when your big house with a bunch on you
start a big house over here in keeping
and in every room I mean that's the only
house because they won the lottery the
weapon buy the house that's like that
weird place in Pacoima
it's a giant that place in Pacoima we're
passing San Fernando mission when we
first came to we came from from the from
the Sinaloa Mexico and we're trying to
come to America we were living at I
don't know we were living a meteor
Julio's house or we're visiting Barlow
and have your house and all night man
you can hear rats eating cardboard and I
hear [ __ ] slap it on girl
I should have fat ass rad TJ before
there how big was it
it was huge I was like that big
yeah it was fat yeah I thought I'm being
right the crisis what are you doing a
remodel for a cat right now the Bert
Kreischer comedian friend that full head
of his cat fought a rat bro and it was a
second round second rat he fought you're
running with it
got that pool they come on everywhere
was he doing a remodel or some [ __ ] a
couple months back I don't know he built
a pool but I don't know I think that's
done I don't know what else he was doing
I got a lot of ivy but if they're
getting inside his house he has issues
sure I know
yeah angel a full is it harder to hustle
out there TJ way harder than it is in LA
how much harder where ever you make yeah
it's a pyramid scheme you can't you can
call you can call her here instead of
shop hey they know who the [ __ ] is up
they know who's from Los Angeles from
the state time these everybody knows
everyone they send the cable yeah
let me follow you no no that's crazy man
they're sophisticated as hell up there
hot dog yeah you know some guy from from
San Diego he came over here and he tried
to sell weed on the corner mm-hmm they
made that food disappeared I should
really make him disappear they
disappeared him okay for you over there
were naked when they shot up LP rap
today seen a law or the Culiacan the low
kid yeah they were combing her hair and
trying to set up shop
uh-huh and taking them vineyard they
start picking them up taking them for a
ride
TV is no joke there's nothing you don't
like you passed by and blew right by
right here right here right here they do
put they were hanging on a bridge to put
a note on you they let everybody know
who you are and what you get away back
and we heard from when we were down in
Mexico shooting that thing that guy The
Fixer guy said that they didn't like
Sinaloa's coming up right people and TJ
didn't like the in all the flowing of
Sinaloa ones into the town right the
[ __ ] lowest of the low eighties yeah
including us were there for a while but
they say they're like changing the
culture of TJ because now you're getting
second in third generation differences
[Music]
hang a white sheet next tune with the
message it's a calling card no joke up
their dog was soft pool was almost
cartoon over there in Mexico that you
need some daddy we grew up with draw
he's out there right now he's out there
bro in Mexico hey bruh
whatever happened to that girl wha
remember that girl she's too little
she's to hang around with them the guy
from a little village [ __ ] a brother
named Alex Torres and she were named
Dahlia or Stella Stella Tori I heard
something bad happened to her yeah
disappear her and her man huh yeah cuz
she showed up she showed up one time I
was doing a show it and I walk to your
ease and then somebody showed up in a
really really bright green fat I'm
really fancy Range Rover and it was um
it was Stella and his three other who
hood rats right and they come out of the
show they come out of the truck like
Kardashian's
and they go inside the club
run away I knew her from the hood
ranking member she's to be part of that
menudo dance group she to dance remember
she to dance with another groups with
other with that girl they used to teach
her dad and Gabi her father used to
teach me guitar and kinda daddy oh yeah
yeah her yeah so she and then she she
has a barrel we brewing give me a
quarter
I haven't seen a long time homie then
they took off in the next thing I heard
was they found him dead wrong really
yeah I don't know I don't know they were
balling that hard you know who loses to
the podcast row Vasquez fake rockers
brother let the tune was a jewel
neighbor oh man no robots had a brother
that was hardcore rocker
I think he's hardcore though hit along
here looks tight jeans all the Kuti sure
whether his brother his brother sister
got the star from him yeah yeah these
negatives are wrong his his this time
but the neighbor he won't be a rock star
to write ugly he little more like a
drummer in rush and that's when I the
fake rocker so that will cut off a
rocker now man without food turn around
a bunch of bison they were real rock
stars [ __ ] another by style they were
stoners yeah they ended up getting jobs
I think a time I called junior and it
will hook me up shout out to them
yourself fool it was a fake rocker what
up dog how about you used to still rock
t-shirt man from [ __ ] up from Carlos
Figueroa us sisters
not the clotheslines we left you there
man aim at everybody how how hot are his
sisters were Mancala Figueroa everybody
want to be a bro
even though everybody bro for the
everybody when they're in their family
didn't look Mexican bro well were they
will it look like they were Irish Irish
best kiss but they were they were you
ever seen that never seen that ad for is
an old ad for Tecate there were these
three girls three white chicks on him
they all had tans and one of them have
really really curly hair and the other
one really tall and blonde you know show
him brunette that was their sisters
probably still faster where they look
but but but I don't know brother
there was the wind I was a bunch of guys
that went to good good I'm good concerts
so what time their clothes hanger bro
nothing about jeans socks and then doors
t-shirt Ozzy Osbourne Iron Maiden
and my brother angel right here me and
Mario and baby James we snagged on bro
but my brother Mara Mario he took the
wrong t-shirt he took the female t-shirt
that half cut and he didn't know a lot
of guys did that a lot of tea but he was
he was extra cozy but it was we're gonna
be baby Jane by walking around bro with
a Judas Priest each circle yeah name one
finger remember them he got the one that
said go goes the food stairs figured or
a sister saw hot
Figueroa up there were not sisters right
yeah yeah boy use only boy yeah how
about Derek Biel Oh everybody what
happen with him in her what everybody
what happened with him and Fifi
there's bill was like the hero in high
school it was the best wrong high school
fever in the city who the best high
school student senior bro like opening
like here to see me off City High School
jacket and the back of his t-shirt and
with him holding a ball with with with
with angel wings because he was of
staying I've been show because you're
the savior of that team bro he was
athletic he was the only guy that didn't
do no drug or are these are gonna no he
didn't do no drugs he wasn't in no gang
affiliations it was all sports like one
time like he was he his his his brother
his cousin with his rival Lamont and
they said [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh yeah okay so those fools had a
one-on-one football game bro and they
chose a quarter yeah it the whole
neighborhood showed up and it was um it
was Derek against Lamont bro and they
were playing don't hike it and they'll
chase each other bro tackle each other
it were a one-on-one then he got into a
fight after but yeah good attention
serious harmful and then it was Lamar's
father came out and he never comes out
the house bro never bro that's worth he
was the only black guy and put the only
guy in the neighborhood they had a
fishing boat parked project the project
people for the county or one time and
when they got in a fight what he come
out for he can want to break up the
fight bro that foo came out with a
[ __ ] a whip he had to have the strap
broke
that's how I broke it up when he came
out he was all [ __ ] tip he came out
looking he came out looking like Steve
bird in the gentlemen's dojo bro the Hat
with a hat like the Gorton's fisherman
looking like Isaac from The Love Boat
and hip waders
they always bagged on their family
because that fool fished so you're gonna
steal you guys other projects
Motherhouse like like fried fish all the
time like you're living in the projects
and there's a big-ass it's a [ __ ] big
boat right in your little boat city like
doesn't this city or this hate like awed
it like wait how can you own a boat and
need we had a brother that worked in
that's amazing that they wouldn't smoke
grandpa get up he had a son and his son
was a big Dodger fan and that fool had
like a hundred Dodger bats remember and
they all belonged to keep Garvey yeah
that's crazy because when we're on
welfare when I was a kid you couldn't
have a savings account
you couldn't have a car I think if
you're on the radar you probably can
yeah I guess maybe he was under the
radar somehow it'll market a big old box
okay play police angel you live in a
mouse house when Western it was living
next door
desert oh they were fighting every night
huh
every night was Royal Rumble it was the
fight about everything
yeah but it's no like next door to us
man they were always fighting and then
then then they'll make up and then won't
happen buy him dinner but we'll offer
them a yeah we're gonna have a dinner
we'll bring you a plate of you want one
cuz they were a family we knew they were
little that couple windows they were
little so they were but then that night
time man they're fighting again in the
morning they're so sorry said Nord
I love God I speak Spanish I love pills
for you hey how about my father it was
funny mixes went I remember when he took
my death battery my dad knew who took
the battery and he went to [ __ ] and
that was the name house [ __ ] he wasn't
named not met those house but the other
point Brown Charlie Brown's house yeah
running sprung challenge wasted the
central football the dollar was a
volleyball player basketball player one
of the end up paralyzed from the neck
down
damn but that was sad that that was I
was just talking about that one other
than that figure that was Fred Wade what
happened to Fred Fred Wayne he went to a
while he got pool he got full full
scholarship to UNLV bro story linebacker
18 and on the second play of practice
broke his leg sad but you know was he
was used to he was used to hitting the
high school kid like that 180 pounds on
me seven pounds he's he ran into some
poor bags that are 222 to warding
full-grown man dude yeah man cause he
played his pain he's playing football
was like you know oh the Val bel god
feel you know like all Latinos Brobee
never really played with crash aw oh
yeah and there were people boss boss you
know Bosco or [ __ ] storm or one
second or second or third year college
students 20 we cracked his name hard bro
and the next day of stab bro the next
day next to cut to two years later that
foo has a frame and his neck and a hole
and a wire sorry bud so he was able to
walk again after know what he was able
to walk again ya know sad was that bro I
was like it was like it was the
equivalent of 911 to everybody in a
project cuz you know we were all
cheering for him we were rooting for you
we were all rooting for you we loved
them and he was not a drug addict his
whole family was but he wasn't yeah
that's a good-ass football school should
not go to that school
hey man ain't remember that one time
that wolf will fly it with [ __ ]
firing Brian told you guys everyone's
way but loose they started a first
playground to the second playground
who's that about did you remember the
fight ended in an ended man it was it
was it was Brian and wolf from Quattro
and they were fighting bro and that fool
is like that fool is crazy but mo had a
he had a he like a real Ruby in his
tooth so when he smiled at she shines
and that put her upper body upper body
proving strange right and then finally
Brian got tired of fighting and then a
fool [ __ ] your pour gasoline a wolf and
and [ __ ] you got a match and say listen
man you wanna continue fighting or what
and that's how it does
and what did start over well that should
start over because they always fire bro
it was like god it was like when Peter
Green yeah but so no matter what like an
ongoing hate Brian was crazy brother
that bro walk away with a leather bout
that says he write her back kill why
people had voted with Hollywood or go to
downtown LA or we have another look
weightlifting bow that was saying a back
killing urge well we were in junior high
and he was like already out of high
school we would laugh I will try again
you up on them I try to fight him and
then [ __ ] it all up what happened to
that fool just on the force or full
whack ass Joe trying to be funny
Church got Steve I think I can hear ice
coming through the back door not funny
you need to run Carlos and chubby friend
not funny you're ok white lady will save
you not funny
come on bro if you're gonna write jokes
write jokes they know Carlos here you
[ __ ] hack get the [ __ ] out of here
put your [ __ ] wack ass jokes if
you're gonna write something bro write a
funny bro goddamn enough with the ice
joke we know ice
we know the wall be more original you
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey that's the guy
that does the the his face is the guy
from mom smiley right the Christian guy
oh that's scary very smiley Spivey yeah
what's up fool one body guys in the
house and funny Matt you go out of the
way and write a whole sentence like that
and then not be [ __ ] funny I mean you
should least write it down the paper
read it if it's not funny don't put it
up goddamn if you into an ice joke make
sure it's funny got there that's him
enough bro enough with the [ __ ]
amateur writers sad jokes and haters get
the podcast paid work so I left Justin
you know just put you in five bucks
ain't you would appreciate it as a part
yes that's how much she makes a month
right how much you make a date no
they're like 5 bucks and then just guess
I've been writing gold mo'fucker you're
writing gold-plated then [ __ ] joke
turned green just like the donation of
tears I make a bond that fool that fool
wrote an unfunny novel that was funny my
[ __ ] right [ __ ] writes
paragraph that suck donkey sure
everybody doesn't donkey show
oh my god didn't see the donkey show oh
my god hey bro go buy a joke book let's
do those jokes but they're funnier what
so he makes a but that third-world
country right now
what stuff well how far do you live for
that wall you know when I was over there
I want to go see those um the wall
the prototype wall yeah the walls on the
other side of the town for me I know I
don't have to close to the border all
right I live I live past like like from
there I live south southeast from there
all right
we are about southeast about 20 20 moved
from there in the interior interior I
know crazy
what's up boo have you ever did you ever
touch your tech boom that guy Jose what
was they the one that died was a million
years in the military just because
you're in the ROTC right hakuna was with
the current sergeant Rutter oh that's
right a fool Huna right Jose Lopez yeah
he's working in the Midwest right now
you never know what we work in the
middle or something what's up [ __ ] so
white boy check come in and say what the
[ __ ] is the point of the show there is
no point it's a part can you [ __ ]
what's the point of anything brother
there is no point why people want a
point why people always want a [ __ ]
message there is no message you
[ __ ] but I applaud the [ __ ] outta
here it's got tongue - you piece of [ __ ]
everybody what the point of the show
there is no point we're just talking
with black bean it's a [ __ ] free show
you [ __ ]
right angel Esparza thank you for
calling do you want it do you need
anything I'll ship it to you you have a
dress I'm Lisa I'll call you later and
that's what that let me know what you
mean like anyone you want clothes or
anything like that or like Marcos
blanket you know who left the show last
week wasn't me man one of the tombs that
audible yeah
[Laughter]
there's like 10 brothers and only one I
was right what what size are you these
days
what's I got 42 XL 2x what's what's your
size right now angel
for clothes this size like shirts and
pants damn the new tree put up with me
42 ways what what leg damn it's like and
then shirts what two extra shirts yeah
what's up fool you're right man
thank you for calling man I Love You Man
take care out there
my brother angel as far as a bro
am i a what's up fool what other guy I
know I was thinking we can have a little
Drive like people drop off stuff if they
want somewhere I wasn't any he's a
manipulator and get money no I'm getting
money got something here we strip in one
box
alright you never said anything to him
before they worship Him stuff clothes
clothes Isis spices like a little prison
sprint Jordans a little thing of water
bottled water or something like man get
him water bottle that cleans water you
know angel funniest bit of joke he
bagged on my ass cuz I'm I just came out
of rehab and then I'm out doing stand-up
comedy then he asked me hey have you
seen yer
kids and I said now I don't see my kids
you know one day they're gonna show up
they'll show up to your show the comedy
show like all wooden [ __ ] like Popeye
they got take out their hat I have a
whole picture of you and say have you
seen my Pappy
[Laughter]
funny you should ever that's here you're
slowly gonna cover it with a Dodger hat
and take out your bingo I received my
movies in this halo you know all his
favorite movies yeah but there's another
one mementos a hardcore movie man no
fool of catch on the rider book the book
yeah that's my priority the first book I
ever read some people crazy
he wrote it he read it he told me he
read it in high school he read it in
high school he read it in prison who
raided calling Joey rated and they keep
playing that so argument because we were
reading a picture our each yeah that's
like Invisible Man for me I've read that
about four times but my mom read Catcher
in the Rye and she wouldn't let me read
it cuz she read it in high school went
into a severe depression that they try
to ban that book a lot yeah I just liked
it because he you should go out at night
there's a great movie called good girl
that takes you on homeless shout out to
Mega Man 6 1980 I think that fool is
gonna start doing stand-up comedy I feel
it you know if you need to go out every
night I mean that's another reason to
stay outside what so for Juan Vargas
Rico Sanchez cuckoo Luke on rare amore
Rico starches and everybody out DJ
having all 50 oh I want to give a shout
out to the woman Mia
our Jesus show you bro what happened I
went back to the doctor brooklet the
ingrown toenail ya fool I thought her to
be one of the regular ones when she just
uses the [ __ ] no clipper and jumps
off no I thought I heard he bro
ah what's she doing baby heard there's
more say yes it hurts more he goes all
right should I know me nah man
how you gonna numb it you're gonna give
me two shots yeah but I didn't a shot
it's gonna feel just as much as you
poking me yeah
just poke me then but they started
poking around no no no no no [ __ ] that
dude
she gave me two shots one another side
of the toe and she waited and she came
back and she put up she rapped over her
band around my toes wait wait wait call
my talk show that [ __ ] are Mayans bro
they turn off that [ __ ] some boys
dude already clear it off what do you
put a rubber band around it she was just
stop the bleeding what bleeding bro I
didn't feel nothing bro just like
tingling then let you took it off less
you [ __ ] wrap the bra in and put a
little I don't [ __ ] back I don't be
be on it the bandage came in he goes I'm
against you suck what was bothering you
what she cut out she called a girl she
could tell now Oh Tony all the way Tony
oh the other way it was a side too
so she had to cut up the whole side and
she showed me brought a little little
sword sword but because he was so busy
he wasn't home on the day she's in the
office that's near us she's like up in
Valencia so he was only home one day a
week for the last two weeks so it's been
killing him so he finally went shoutout
to Elon Musk and Joe Rogan smoking that
louis xiii
by the way that woman oh yeah her name
is go follow her on instagram and i
don't know she has a GoFundMe or
something but she her name is just smile
just smile my Mia mi a she's got she
listens to podcasts all the time she's
got stage for chronic Menace medicine
man estatic
breast cancer and she's like if you go
to her page like if she lets you follow
her she's got some
war wounds from the chemo she's doing
right now that's really rough like she's
like the fly like she's falling apart
for this chemo you know it's real sad
but she's keeping her spirits up and she
said she loves the podcast she loves
your special and it all makes her feel
better
good yeah this was said I heard of the
play the teacher called Casa little PS
Emilia Maria yeah man I saw you know I
saw when I went to her page
I heard you mom like she's taking this
oral chemo like it's necrotic oh my god
turns black and then skin falls off
speaking of cancer we [ __ ] or dilatory
right into our George Lopez and the hot
cheetos guy at the Riverside for Cheech
and he [ __ ] ready to prepare Zelda
yeah he told me I'm gonna contact oh my
God he's like free again yeah oh my god
you understand this guy this guy hates
on everyone to those characters we
didn't really get those characters my
person is from American me born Easter
lay in the church the jerk he's in a car
of Latinos that pulls the church in the
man who know the man in a white suit
yeah yeah dude he was terrible he was
just saying that there's 20,000 so yeah
he was all into it he said we're just
super busy he was hanging out a little
drink and stuff bumping into people we
were at we were asked them at some house
one time at a party indoor Chuck this
woman was talking about how she beat
cancer without doing them chemotherapy
natural unnatural that was that option
see movie what's his name
he said well yes I was producing right
and East I was there and so was on plant
food for the people right and the
Pristina was there man it was Anna they
say some would say something that he
disagreed with he would you Yap with us
we're [ __ ] dying I'm telling you man
anyway our faces
and movie Scarface that's right anybody
that was that wasn't home or angel
anybody that does side jokes next to me
at a man Dean or somewhere where I want
to be yet I was an elaborate joke oh
yeah so paper-thin is like so people
something goes yeah mess well I didn't
do the chemotherapy I want to do the
natural way if a person goes [ __ ] Danny
that's not painful I went for the
[ __ ] chemo I think you know chance
okay grew back white he had cancer -
yeah he was doing the rapping grandpa
full room with the little I know that
when he was in Corpus Christi he would
do I school with Farrah Fawcett and they
went out you know when I was she wanted
me one time I also met I heard from
while some sources there's team Trevino
said that he dated Eva Longoria and
let's say people watch soap or
podcasting for listening I heard it for
woolly bears